oh hello there welcome to honest trailer
commentaries the show where we talk
about the show you just watch in this
case hopefully it was the honest trailer
for Deadpool to starting another the
Deadpool himself guys we did it again
yeah who could have seen this coming
everyone everywhere star Dan Merrill
it's very exciting that's still those
special J Albert and that's me
yeah this is the show we're gonna talk a
little more in detail about our thoughts
on that film we don't have any deleted
scenes we used everything we got but we
do have a I won't call it rejected
version of the script but do you know
one that we didn't think was good enough
so that's what you get to hear if you
stick around to the end shall we discuss
Deadpool 2 or Ryan Reynolds what should
we start with let's start with Ryan
Reynolds yeah but that's why most people
have clicked on this video yes did you
know buddies you vile worms scum-sucking
Hollywood bottom feeders talk to a
golden God like that well the trick is
you just email them and you ask politely
he is the email address listed below on
your screen I've been playing this game
as we've been emailing back and forth is
nicest person in the world or just
Canadian and I'm still still undecided I
think every Canadian is this nice but
he's definitely Canadian so does it
matter at that point I don't know yeah
yeah are you Canadian if you're not nice
no they kick yeah yeah I think you're
you're booted yes yes your bow did you
do the who with employers yeah he's like
this guy in the world
we had his contact info from the
previous collaborations and of course
Deadpool 2 was approaching quickly and
Spencer was elected to be the contact
person and we emailed him and he said
yes and then we emailed him an idea and
he said here's a better one yeah we sent
him and maybe we won't make him wait
till the end we sent him a script there
was basically what we usually what we
did for Logan which was like hey well
maybe we'll call Deadpool at the end and
we'll have a little quick back and forth
and he's like what nice but we've done
this
and we even say it in the script no
you're doing the same thing again yeah
so he offered to do the honest trailer
for honest trailers I'm like [ __ ] yeah
yeah exactly great I think yeah you know
the first time around there was a lot to
it a sound guy was sent to him blah blah
blah and I think we really just as each
time goes we want to like bother him
less so yeah we want phone route again
and yeah it was nice enough to yes the
stakes for yeah yeah I don't think we
were gonna feel comfortable like being
like here's a 15 page opus Reynolds
worked for free yeah we didn't want to
do the over ask yeah we didn't really
even know if he would respond at all but
he did which is very nice yes even to
say no would have been nice if he would
just said like thanks but I'm busy like
that's so nice of you thank you so I
guess in gay and there were rewrites and
he offered his is such a nice dude he
seems like a genuine a fan or a really
solid bullshitter and one actor doesn't
even matter doesn't matter I will say
that we ended our correspondence with
saying something about we won the
2016-2017 energy streaming for best
collaboration on honest trailers and
Ryan Reynolds for Deadpool and we
offered we had noticed he'd been
promoting his gin company we offered to
trade him our Streamy for a bottle of
gin and he sent us a bottle it did he
sent his 24 bottles
oh yeah there's a case of gin so so
thank you for this delicious a BS home
I believe I'm pronouncing that right is
the Montreal yeah it's very botanical
it's smooth it's it's got a nice bite to
it and here Ryan Reynolds will leave
your stream me right here you can come
by any time we know you want right here
with you
can you help up you're into the bargain
yeah you sent us the gin was your home
address any time you want to come pick
it up here you go yeah we'll have a
drink we have a few bottles of gin here
mm-hmm
you send an assistant you know we don't
care we'll drink yeah he'll be ours now
but we don't want just some random
person now showing up there has to be
someone at home you're like hi I'm Ryan
Reynolds assistant and they're gonna
abscond with our
trophy so excellent point well need some
kind of no false assistant absconders um
should we talk about Deadpool - at all
I mean we would have done a normal
honest trailer for this even if he said
no yeah are we gonna do if you said that
we're gonna try to ask Colossus no
you're gonna and then I think we were
gonna try to ask Rob Liefeld John
Bailey's impression of Ryan Reynolds
he's done some as the Senate lackeys
form yeah yeah okay sorry we're down the
wrong pipe I'd like to remark its high
durability whether it's in your
esophagus or your lungs it's very smooth
yeah highly recommend it drink
responsibly literally though don't
breathe it down your throat
sorry so yeah that was those were our
alts Deadpool two aides of it's a lovely
film I mean I don't yeah I think we set
it up top all that we were gonna say
which is like it's really good it wasn't
a surprise anymore but it was good
he saved us a lot of work as far as yeah
really figuring out what to say cuz it's
it's that horrible combination of a
funny comedy and a good movie I mean I I
enjoyed it myself as much as or the
first I saw it twice and I was like it
was it I really really liked it and it
would have been very difficult much like
infinity war last week it's hard to do a
good movie it's really hard to do a good
movie good movies are hard to do yeah
here were my broad notes brought in do
you really remote to over the girls get
it I do and this isn't even a bad thing
but here here we go
it over compensated for the small scale
the first one they were like too big
it's like it's kind of like eight movies
at the same time you got the firefish
story you got the Deadpool Vanessa story
you got the cable story you can the
foreman of the x-force they seem like
they're like we might never get to make
another one of these again let's put
everything out in here boom roasted boom
roasted
yeah
I do think similar to Deadpool one where
everything could have been wrapped up if
he and Vanessa had just talked mm-hmm
if he and cable had just talked it out
for a few minutes almost ever
that'll we'll sit down had like maybe
two more sentences in there in the word
fourth a nice bottle of aviation that's
enough then yeah we were not paid for
this it was a it was a barter system
it's a gift it's for one streaming it's
yes one stream II for for one bottle of
gin that's the going rate for a Streamy
yeah just for my commercial yeah and
then the only other thing is that his
girlfriend lives in the sunken place for
white people she's kind of like at a
remove from everything in the sunken
place well you really ripped that movie
a new ass suck it to 20 P to DP to God
she was a perfect fun movie with a much
better story than I expected yes it was
the first one one of my favorite a comic
book movie narratives of recent years it
was good there you go mmm so let's watch
our honest trailer for Deadpool 2 for
honest trailers with Deadpool
after Deadpool one came out of nowhere
and made everyone lose their [ __ ]
minds a sequel will rise that's just as
good if not better
making audiences everywhere say this
one's good too
it's like having a surprise party but
this time it's not a surprise and it
came three weeks after a funeral the
same cultural impact I think well but
that's it's its own fault for being good
the first time well and it's the the
summer schedule of like you can see got
solo mixed in there to an infinity war
still it's like you know was when it
came out the first time it's like
February there's not as much clutter
around it you can it can play out for a
while plus yeah it's it's it's the
problem of like when you have a great TV
show and then the next season is also
great it's but yeah well that's the
challenge with this too is the first one
was this you know even before it was
made or released it had this whole like
rogue story behind it of Fox didn't want
to make it man and then the footage got
leaked and and and then everyone was
like kind of excited on that level many
finally they're doing it justice
yeah and they already did it just and
then they really nailed it but now it's
become like like Fox was like oh this is
our this is our beautiful little child
now it's a part of them the machine in
the rotation and yeah yeah and now it's
Disney we shall see we shall see yeah
all right let's keep going you know
world hold the door
hit the brakes cut dead who know it's
Banksy would you like to buy a painting
yes yes we're going with this what could
be in the world this is a kerb on Disney
blah blah blah pretending to give a [ __ ]
about shatters - yeah we could have done
a whole tea Jimmy like really not what
yeah yeah you're right we're gonna say
that even doing Deadpool - listen to
your commenters and tear KOCO a new ass
all already let's address that because
all that people said why haven't you
done coke yeah cowards it's true it's
it's it's really good what do you say
about cocoa what do you say it's not you
don't even have the angle of insight out
about being inside the heads it's like
it's a really sweet story about family
I'll say we're ducking coca or deco I
the only section I can even think of is
this music was really good and I could
have used a few more song whoa this
animations vibrant too vibrant some
might say moving on like I said there
were so many comments last week they
were like why did you go so easy on
infinity war it's like cuz it's good
trailer it's not crap on everything
trailers we're not gonna just dump on a
movie you're cowards cuz you don't think
my thoughts for no reason so yeah I
agree we're ducking Coco we're not doing
it yeah nope not gonna happen I'm never
in it keep going
next year women in film $10,000 Coco Oh
connects what's happening pause so we
had fun coming up with these what do we
got there Peter and Peter boxes
Deadpool reacts that's in the continuity
from our first Deadpool trailer where he
started doing react video so after react
world happened and it's a story mr.
Deadpool movies a shout out to how can
we both honor and insult mr. something
as the only Australian words we know
yeah yeah we're dead letter media yeah
get those hat front so yeah we've showed
us to all our faves and then Ryan
Reynolds due to the proposal yeah nice
alright keep going
Oh from whatever Internet company owns
them this week that's been chugging
along for six it's been six years no
everyone knows it's time to let it go
man honest trailers be honest trailer
graphics been great these days
well most of them watch these closets he
knew about that nada that's not a sneaky
like you know he recorded it we snuck
that in to his credit his only note was
the first thing you sent me is is just a
repeat of what we did before it do
something different yeah that was
absolutely no so everything you see in
the script was all there yeah he knew
what we were doing yep so there you go
yeah well did you want to talk about
what it's like to try to write on an
honest trailer of honest trailers as us
as Deadpool well I I will say it's
freeing a lot there's uh there's a
little bit of poetry there's poetry cuz
um when we approached him about doing
the honest trailer he was like what we
tried to do an honest trailer being of
Deadpool and we couldn't crack it so we
were like how about this and he was like
okay great and everyone always wants us
to an honest trailer for honest trailers
and which we said would be too hard
because it's too self referential but in
doing it as Deadpool gives us an agenda
outside point of view yeah which was his
idea to do the honest trip so yeah yeah
Bryant cemetry yeah beautiful poetry
yeah yeah I don't know it's a he kind of
had to take a step back because there
were a few drafts of this and I think
really ones I don't recall I feel like
they weren't they weren't hitting us
hard enough yeah they were too inside
and then yeah insulting enough - yes
exactly so like we need it we need to be
real about our flaws and our tropes and
and we've got we've got just as much as
anyone else does so it was
it was a healing process it was it was
very good yeah it's very therapeutic to
get out what what I feel are the things
that are legitimate things about the
show mm-hmm so there you go we're gonna
fix any of them no no we gotta we can't
at this point yeah most of them watch
these nerds find one logic gap and
pretend like it ruin the whole movie
well actually if cable changed the
future if you wouldn't have to travel
back in the first place dude is
California no you pedantic horse [ __ ]
it's a movie about a cyborg cartoon
Europe within which couches and tiny
feet stop pretending it's the real world
revisit all the classic honest trailer
tropes like the park where they just say
bewbs for no reason actually we've kind
of moved away run its course smart
choice part where they're slower fans
keep requesting trailers for movies that
are still in theaters I think that was
our little moment of self-expression
it's not it's not that we think that our
fans are slower but no but the people
who request venom before it's ours and
Amazon or gonna have the Meg the week
after it comes out is like one of the
New York we would literally be arrested
if we did the Meg right now we would
have federal agents at our door asking
hey how did you do that yeah um so due
respect
yeah we can't we cannot do movies before
they're illegally we'll just do one more
step of thinking before you write just
one more that are still in theaters
unlike Deadpool - super duper cut
available now on blu-ray and Digital and
the starring section which actually
isn't bad but my movie did it way better
like half of yours are just bad puns no
Pepsi games need some more seals Club
Jesus joke don't talked about in the
same sentence as Jesus that way I am
then you Deadpool and watch that movie
is grossly an r-rated movie of all time
except for Jesus pause yeah I'd watch
Deadpool - it I was like oh
interesting so that's how it is you know
I'm sure we're tight on that whoever's
everything - right yeah punch up on
those scripts just saying Ryan I'm a
bottle of ginger and I'm gonna have us
for two bottles were yours we cannot
wait to disappoint tens of millions of
them don't let us disappoint people on a
larger scale yeah and this streaming for
you yeah anyways because I don't want
this going to be a clickbait article of
just like honest trailers accuses
Deadpool creative team most it we're not
we're not like legitimately angry like
hey you stole our joke it's like I'm
pretty whatever Joe sorry I'm furious
like main article joestar beefing with
string Joestar beefs with our are like
sorry that's gonna be the scoops know
about that yeah oh boy these on top of
that story where it's gonna be he's in
your trash solid food in its diet is in
my trash yeah my cat has soft poops
video I do not need to be here I could
be playing fortnight with Drake ninja
and Mike Pence right now sorry with all
of that man I knew who Mike that's our
show that may be all kinds of turgid
let's try that a little harsh I mean we
have been nominated for three Emmys
wait this is also doubling as our Emma
campaign so if you're watching voting
thank you people we're done here wait
yeah he'll be back for detective Pikachu
yeah we had written a thing there about
Arkell and julia white and the laureate
more nominations than Urkel no it was
harsh on us good see little white
deserves way more ma nominations than
we've got Dan don't suck up to Jaleel
White he's not here I know deserves an
emmy
oracles an icon deserves an emmy I'm
saying is there's an Emmy nomination
there's a difference he carried our
country for a lot years now stefan
urquelle that guy had style he could get
Steve Urkel no way have I got something
to tell you
what if I told you they were the same
person
balderdash yeah that was fun fun doing
them all everything about that was fun
and slightly surreal that had happened
yeah just the idea of exchanging emails
yeah with Ryan and then there's his
angelic voice on the other end and the
other never recording damn and he sends
straight to us yeah yeah yeah crazy it's
good dude
I really appreciated when he when he's
just like you know what let's do
something a little different yeah yeah
that was awesome so promised to him we
should say there was two also we didn't
have time because we just finished the
trailer which is the alt title for a
dead horse was a minimum a minimum
effort yeah and then the starring nobody
you ever heard of we we took a shot of
ourselves out of that originally it was
over a shot of us and we're like that
seems a little self adult
yes so and now it shows like for the
people yeah so yeah should we read the
alternate scream oh yeah this is your
first version we who wants to be
performing parts gave this Marmee is so
you got to be Ryan Reynolds oh I guess
we have to work up one script only
printed one oh all right you'll be the
epic voice okay all right so this is
after a theoretical regular Deadpool to
honest trailer hit it Joe all right hold
on a second this is a long shot but let
me see what I can do ring ring ring ring
Moshi Moshi
Deadpool buddy it's me from honest
trailers really the same [ __ ] call
Deadpool bit you know just cuz you're
doing a sequel doesn't mean you have to
beat the same dead horse again do I look
like Jack Sparrow Dinu please Deadpool
to came out and we don't have that much
new to say about it well plug your
blu-ray release first like my blue
Supercat buh buh-buh-buh you want me to
go fire it fine you want to go viral one
more time let's do it your pal DP is
more viral than a comic-con doorknob and
then here small it's more viral than a
Coachella button Club butt plug more
viral than a dog with canine AIDS
welcoming home a veteran who also has
canine AIDS too much
Coachella but club by the way is just as
good as Coachella but I like that
writing process is very Jeff Foxworthy
like take it from ear boss
so experience the cinematic achievement
of the century that one ups all of
Deadpool's trademark hilarious jokes and
also his depression the death of his
only love the torture of children the
murder of cables wife and infant
daughter hey are you gonna multiple
attempted suicide before Deadpool 2 is a
serious [ __ ] movie you pony riding
[ __ ] wrinkle actually give it a language
warning yeah this is a language that
ninja alright alright and as I was
saying a classic [ __ ] x-men
time-travel ending that makes everything
hunky-dory again in the end see now tell
me I didn't Kerri Strug the [ __ ] out of
that landing I'm sorry I doubted you mr.
cool reference oh yeah very topical
thank you so much this is the line I
like trust the professionals kid now
[ __ ] off I got a meeting with Kevin
Feige to see how many [ __ ] jokes I can
stick in Avengers night you say are you
gonna join the Mouseketeers you said I
wouldn't join the x-men no way I'm
joining the Mouseketeers Mouseketeers
yeah yeah so there you go that was the
same bit we did before
instead we flipped it the new bits
better Ryan Reynolds made us butter yeah
that's all right
and isn't that true of all of us Cheers
isn't that true of aviation gin the only
gin to enjoy well commentating out a
movie of your choice make a Deadpool -
super duper cut checks in the mail
streamys on the table and stream we made
a deal fair and square
yeah we'll honor our end yeah again
thank you for watching Ryan and others
but mostly right come back next week
where I'll be back next week maybe
that's that ahead we later leave you all
just go and warm them up we're
working on Doctor Who guys and it's a
slog if we seem a little loopy it's not
just the aviation gin it's that we've
watched a hundred and something episodes
of Doctor Who were simply [ __ ]
they've watched the modern stuff I've
been traveling to the 60s and 70s with
classic Doctor Who while they complain
about watching the new stuff so it's
still suck it yeah anyways
well we'll give you an update closer
then but we might need a binge week but
we very does we will put out something
YUM that's our promise you'll like it
that's not our profit it's no guarantees
we'll see you eventually thanks for
watching honest trailer commentaries bye
bye
[Music]
you